those people do well naturally anyway I
mean I've had people there some of the
best people I've interviewed of always
say hi everyone I don't think I'm gonna
get it I'm gonna fun so uh what we're
going to talk about today is really the
process of moving from your secure on
premise to hybrid and then into cloud I
think as you've heard throughout next at
Google we're invested in trying to
reduce the obstacles the concerns that
you don't need to have to accelerate and
elevate the way you do development so
that you can grow businesses grow your
applications and be successful
especially in security what we were
talking about as always played out is
cloud should be the immune system for
you to protect you against cyber attacks
something you don't have to actively
manage something that in fact is there
in the background always defending you
now we recognize that not all of you in
the same space in terms of moving to the
third generation cloud many of you are
have on-premise facilities have needs to
have workloads that are both in an
on-premise situation as well as in the
cloud and really the key is to for us to
give you the controls to allow you to
manage to trust the way you need as
niels pointed out beyond just the
underlying security and trust built into
our core platform beneath Google we need
to continuously provide you the controls
to access those capabilities so you can
secure your workloads the way you need
them to be so at the core of what we're
talking about at Google the security is
really based on four key principles
trust and transparency control audit
compliance and innovation and what we
mean by this is it's not just sufficient
for us to have superior technology trust
that you have in us and what we do is
really built and being transparent about
things and that's part of Neal's his
talk earlier today was one of the steps
to give you a sense of what really goes
on behind the scenes
in addition for control from enterprises
and businesses you need the ability to
have access to the capabilities to
configure and run your business and
control the user service data access
levels as you need fraud and compliance
our commitment is to make sure that
addition of the certifications that we
have on our cloud we're going to be able
to support you to get the certifications
that you need to run your businesses and
of course we're all focused on
innovation right whether it's the
machine learning that Jeff talked about
the essentially the super power of
having cloud machine learning added to
your capabilities really the ability to
have you focus on your business and then
for us to take care of the rest
so for today's talk we're going to focus
however on folks who are not yet in the
generation three cloud right and the
common questions we get in security
really fall into five main categories
right how do you match identify and
access control so that the policies that
you already have today can be reflected
in the cloud that you move to network
security how do you create the isolation
and trust zones that you need to
segregate your users and information as
you might like data protection how is
your data your users data your customers
data protected and how do you control
that threats and vulnerabilities how
really access to and breeches and
intrusions are handled so that you are
protected upfront and ultimately audit
logging the things that allow you to
know what's going on in your systems to
know every access every action so in
order to do this we're going to use an
example to walk you through a
step-by-step process of migrating from
an on-premise application to a hybrid
situation where part of the application
runs in cloud and then finally to a full
GCP instance now to do this we tried to
pick a small representative example
application so we've created a meme
generation which is built on a lamp
stack it has a my sequel database an
Apache front-end
and basically it allows you
to start out in the cloud and in
on-premise and we'll move it step by
step for so let's go so the first step
as we talked about was taking your
existing identities and your policies
and how does that come with you in cloud
so you don't have to change and do other
things so to help me talk through that
and invite I meet Johnny who is the
product manager for I Danny for cloud on
to walk you through your identity
Federation Thank You Andi your voice so
Andy thought any night we're walking
through a potential scenario here and we
thought it would be kind of fun fun
being relative you know last day of a
conference kind of fun I guess but to
walk through an actual customer type of
example right to really represent what
our customers go through Andy and I talk
to a lot of customers and we've hearing
very we switch the outside screen we
thought it'd be fun to kind of walk
through what that would look like
so one of the things we thought we
should walk you through is a typical
scenario of a customer right you already
have an identity provider you already
have a source of truth for your
identities where you've defined users
and groups and what you really want is
just to carry that with you into the
cloud right and so what you're going to
see let's do exactly that we're going to
use a IDP we can talk to it insert your
name of your identity provider here
whether it's Active Directory or anybody
else and we're going to fit right though
your users and groups to Google and then
the next thing we're going to do is just
show you how those now exist they're
federated all you have to do is assign
permissions to your groups and
everybody's there and then lastly I
think just to prove that this is a
federated identity use case we're going
to delete a user and identity provider
and show you how quickly that reflects
so just to highlight what we talked
about here you'll see these very
complicated art graphics here but you'll
see the non Google identity provider
your identity user source of truth it
gets federated to Google and then you
just assign the users that better there
so why don't we jump into the demo
Andy's gonna drive us for a drive it for
us here but you'll see this is our
identity provider in this case we use
ping you can use any open store you can
use any identity provider that you like
most of them come with a Google
connector as ping does and so the idea
is then that you connect ping to your
Google environment and your source of
truth is now connected so here you'll
see in
very simplified example we have users
that are assigned here and each of these
users are already assigned to a group
and so Andy will show you here that
these groups exist and I think the key
wants to focus on are the network
administrator the network viewer and the
security administrator these are the
sample types of groups that we've
created and the users that we've talked
about earlier which were Bob Bob Amy and
AJ who are signed into each of these
groups and we'll see how that carries
over when you get into cloud so then I
once you've federated it so here's
examples of that group once those users
are and groups are federated you'll be
able to come to your Google console at
which Andy will do now and you'll be
able to see both of those things right -
just to prove that it is in fact
federated when you make a change in your
identity provider the users show up here
so here you'll see Bob AJ and of course
Amy reflected here and they're already
assigned to those groups because the
groups have also been federated with you
so as you click into AJ for example
you'll be able to see he's already a
member of this group in this case the
network viewer group and the same will
be true for Bob and the same will be
true for Amy as well right in this
example just just to quickly touch on
those users those roles where the rules
are network viewer is obviously a
read-only kind of role a network admin
is somebody who can create new networks
and take networking type functionality
and a security admin our hero of the
story here is the one who can do
security actions but not necessarily
network actions so then why don't we
jump into the iam windows so those of
you who are familiar you come into the
cloud console you'll see Andy's already
created those the group's already there
they pre populate when you do a search
or when you do when you create a new
member and he's assign them to a group
so here you can see the roles already
assigned compute network admin compute
network viewer and of course computer
the computer security admin so those are
predefined roles that already exist
within I am and you can just assign them
to the group note here we didn't assign
a single user to a role there that
automatically gets inherited when you
become a member of that group so why
don't we we've kind of done the setup
here why don't we actually live a day in
the life of loose pretend we're a me amy
was the security administrator so amy
comes in she logs into our single
sign-on system here and then she should
get redirected directly into the Google
castle the Google Cloud console or not
you've got a console of that developer
just as a show of hands how many of you
are using ping just out of curiosity
turn understand okay how many I'm
guessing most of you are Active
Directory okay that's what I figured are
there others of note that we should you
can scream I'm out whoa Google okay so
here you see a now Amy's logged in you
can see that she's in fact logged in
she's because she's a security
administrator she really has no business
going through comment dashboards and GAE
screens and GCE screens so we'll jump
into the networking screen here remember
she's a security administrator so when
we come to networks as the option you'll
see she cannot in fact create networks
she can't do firewalls you can't do our
student she can't do VPNs she can't do
routers and things like that but in fact
when she goes into firewalls she should
be able to create a firewall she is a
security administrator right and and
take the action there so again she's
already been assigned the role without
having to explicitly do that if we were
to do the same for a bob for example we
can we can come in and be Bob for a
moment you can see in this case that's
me but
okay here we are at Bob again bob is a
network administrator so no need to be
in any comment screen here but if you
jump into the networking you'll find
what you expect right that Bob can in
fact create networks can create the VPNs
can create DNS load balancers but when
you take it to the firewall rules of
course is unable to do anything there
and then we can do the same for AJ as
well right AJ again had a viewer role so
we'd have well let andy jump into the
yep here we go so that we can jump into
the networking itself and you find in
fact only read-only screens right you
can take action it can only take
viewership I can't do any actions
themselves as expected right no rocket
science here so I think that's kind of
the high-level overview of the identity
sync today most commercial and almost
all open-source identity providers have
a natural bridge into Google Apps and
Google so that should naturally work but
let's walk through an example we talked
about concluding here with the showing
true Federation so why don't we delete
AJ
and then when you go into admin console
and do a refresh you'll find that AJ
fingers crossed
will have disappeared from all this
there you go
AJ is no longer there so it's it's a
live system it happens instantaneously
so you don't have to the minute somebody
decides to go on to better opportunities
and are no longer at your cut but you're
able to remove them premiere identity
provider and they completely get
shutdown from access to the cloud
console so that's that's the high-level
summary here Andy why don't I transition
it back to you yep so lesson number one
from migrating from your on-premise
situation to either a hybrid or cloud is
that you in fact can bring your
identities you don't need to recreate
them you're able to federate and use the
existing privileges and I am to enforce
them so the next thing where you talk
about is the hybrid cloud and so what do
we mean by the hybrid Club so today what
we're going to talk to you about is
first from the mean jem app in the
on-premise situation and those you
probably can't see it but this is
actually the on-premise server so if we
go to that on-premise server this is the
meme gem app for that server and it's a
little tiny on-premise server it's live
the other thing we'll talk about is the
project that we just showed you the
controls and I am for so it's the mean
gen next 16 application and today we
have a front end so we've split it now
so that we're gonna move keep the back
end on the server and have the front end
showed up in cloud so this is the front
end the instance PHP piece and right now
though if I go to that one that web site
you notice it's not connecting anything
because we actually haven't created H
VPN a trusted connection between the two
so we're going to fix that
so what we're going to do now is
leverage the networking that we just
talked about before so I'm logged in as
kanji and kanji if you'll write remember
whoops is one of the other roles that
create it has both network permissions
and also has security permissions oops
so as someone who has Network
Commission's and security permissions
he's able to basically go as we said
before not do anything with the main
dashboard but he can create both
Networks VPNs and routes so we're going
to create a VPN so currently there's a
VPN we're going to connect the front
piece which was the instance to the back
end
and we're going to use the sub Network
that's created leveraging the sub
network technology we have it's in the
US central region and we create a static
IP address so we can do the VPN
connection so we'll use that now on the
other side we need a similar static IP
address which we've locked in for the
on-premise example it's i ke v2 and we
need a shared secret now I would not
recommend this shared secrets because
it's a little bit simple but for the
purposes of this demonstration we're
going to go ahead and use that so now we
have to use the local connections here
and then connect to the subnet now for
the sake of this demo we're showing this
through menus but in fact you can have
the run g-cloud in our sdk so the same
commands can be scripted or if you're
running purely in the services mode we
give you the api's to allow you to run
this - so at scale instead of in this
simple example you would be doing this
with automation so let's go ahead and
create this VPN so now it's going to
take a little bit time for the VPN to
load so while we're doing this we'll
talk about what's going on so as we said
before from the on-premise server we
have the my sequel database and we're
connecting to a front-end instance each
of the VMS has its own individual
firewalls so we had to set the details
for the firewall and we'll show that a
little bit the web applications of the
front-end now each of the individual
identities has different control over
the settings the ability to either
control the VPN the firewall and
underlying pieces so as what we're
taking advantage of here is really
several things in our now that the
features on our network the ability to
create private IP spaces so that when
you connect to us you're no longer
traveling on the open Internet you're
travelling within our private network
and your traffic stays on our private
network encrypted as it moves for in
addition we're taking advantage of the
ability how
sudden networks the ability really lock
in and segment your trust the way you
need to based on how you want to control
the connections and access between roles
and finally we're taking advantage of
the VPN so as you notice now that the
the VPN connection is green so we're
going to go back and see if we can hit
that same node before and see if it's
connected
so and so we are we're now connected and
we're on our way to full clap so
basically we have the database the my
sequel database connected on the back
end we have the PHP front-end serving up
traffic so one of the steps of the ways
they're using our network and our and
capabilities to allow us to get there so
lesson number two you can create the
zones of trust that you need by
leveraging the capabilities and network
that we've talked about in addition one
of the opportunities when you have the
front-end now on GCP is also leverage
the load balancing that you heard about
yesterday in the networking talk which
gives you both performance scaling and
also amount of DDoS protection built in
so the next thing we're going to talk
about is going to full GCP so going back
again to the is the underlying and so
you'll make sure we're the right course
so going back again to from a role
standpoint to an owner role I can take a
look at again they brought the overall
project
and with the go look at the overall
project we have in addition to the
front-end that we just triggered which
is this one we also have the ability to
go back and look at the full lamp stack
version so we've done is set up a full
abstract version we've migrated
everything over the other thing if you
guys were paying attention when I showed
you each of the first two the on premise
one and also the hybrid one those were
actually only an HDTV P so at Google
obviously we're big fans and implement
TLS and SSH so this is actually a full
HTTP connection on on our Google cloud
platform implementing the my sequel
database as well as the PHP front-end
now once you get fully on our cloud the
question is you have now moved your data
here but how do we connect and continue
to connect so that you can do this fast
so we have a large number of different
ways for you to migrate your data on to
our clouds through VPN through direct
peering through your internet working in
addition once your data is in our cloud
really the question is how do we protect
it so we really give you three options
of how to protect your data first by
default your data is encrypted and it's
actually encrypted three ways the
underlying data is first charted and
chunked then each of those pieces are
encrypted the chunk key is then
encrypted and a wraping key around the
chunk key is encrypted and those are
then stored in a key store which manages
and rotates them as necessary or if you
want to encrypt your data before you
give it to us you certainly have that
option you have full control in that
case finally you can give us customer
supplied keys and then we can go ahead
and trip things for you without us being
able to actually look at your data
additionally yesterday I think we talked
to you about audit logging so what we're
going to show you is this is a
screenshot we're going to show you the
live logs again off of this GCP instance
so what we're seeing here now is the
events that created after the firewall
we can look at the events that create
off the meme Network which is the sub
Network and all those things are
accessible to you both in the activity
stream you can search on them we can
filter out purely on activity we can
filter out and looking at a range of
resources within all the resources
within compute and if you look at all
the different resources the choices
allow you to look at a wide range of
both packets changes in iam permissions
therefore than other pieces so finally
when you think about going on to a
platform it's important that the
underlying platform has the governance
and the compliance pieces that you need
in case you need to run those for your
business so the Google cloud platform is
regularly certified for sock to and sock
3 ISO 27001 and then PCI DSS 3 zero and
we're engaged in supporting you to get
the end-to-end certifications as you run
your business on partially on our cloud
as well as the other pieces that you
that you're running in your own business
so lesson number three if when you once
you are comfortable with bringing the
data on to our cloud you're then fully
encrypted by default and your TLS
everywhere but this is really just
getting you to where you are now moved
from offer on premise to a cloud
environment but you're still at this
point using the cloud in a way similar
to how you would have before and your
on-premise as we've talked about
throughout next the next the what we
really want you to be able to do is
focus on building great apps and great
businesses and let us take care of the
operations and really live in a server
list kind of environment so since we've
been talking about security another
thing you may have noticed is you know
we talked about lamp stack but it's all
in PHP so how do you deal with that
all right so PHP has a range of security
vulnerabilities that people try to
exploit and part of that then is for us
to implement as we have automated
scanning
so if you bring your applications to our
App Engine product we have in general
availability cloud security scanner it's
an optimum its website scanner that
basically finds some of the most common
vulnerabilities proactively before you
deploy an example here is if you look at
the OS top-10 injection cross-site
scripting components with known
vulnerabilities those are all very
common things that occur in Web Apps and
cause breaches so our security scanner
detects cross-site scripting mixed
content insecure libraries and in 2016
we'll be rolling out in addition to
sequel injection and also the bilious
scan applications on GCE and other other
installations in addition we'll be able
to tie user features around
notifications for you and the ability to
automate those skins so what now we're
going to show you a little bit is how to
actually how the scanner works
so what we have here is an application
which we call firing range
we open source that a couple years ago
it is the basis on which most web
vulnerability scanners test against to
make sure they find sources of
cross-site scripting mixing the mixed
content and library pieces so we're
going to do is show you what one of
these scan results looks like so in this
project we have an application called
public firing range if you're in App
Engine you get a tab that's specifically
security scans and then you're able to
look at a range of scan results so if we
look at the scans that we ran last night
it hit 657 URLs in the application and
feyten to over 600 vulnerabilities and
those vulnerabilities range from
cross-site scripting 420 of them an old
library mixed content so for example the
particular application uses jQuery
that's out of date so that would be an
immediate flag and something you could
fix in addition we have in detail for
the cross site scripting errors the
ability for you to drill down into each
of these errors and in fact both
replicate it to find out where it
actually occurs in your code fix it
remediate it and this is all in
development before you deploy to
production so it catches things before
they actually hit production currently
what we've seen with folks who've used
the security scanner is that when it's a
cross-site scripting error once
identified 80% of the users go back and
in fact fix it and remediate so that's a
large number of potential
vulnerabilities that have been
eliminated before any of the code hits
production so the lesson really then is
continue to move to higher levels of
abstraction right abstraction automation
of your friends and we provide you the
ability to leverage that today through
App Engine through bigquery and through
data flow so you're really living the
server list kind of no operations mode
and that becomes a next step of what you
can do once you've gone from on-premise
to hybrid to
and then to the true third-generation
cloud so finally you know what's next
after this in recap what we've talked
about is identity Federation the ability
for you when you already have in place
installs to take those with you for us
for you not to have to recreate them and
for us to basically respect them enforce
the roles and access policies that you
have in addition we talked about the
network security needed to isolate and
create the trust owns that you have
through VPN through the sub networking
talked about the data protection the
built-in encryption as well as the
control that you have to further encrypt
and protect your data and then we talked
about the logging and then the
abstractions and automation so
ultimately what's next after this from
the cloud security side those of you
have done some of the code labs the
specific details of how we've built each
of these pieces which we wouldn't
couldn't get into today on stage you can
actually walk through each step in the
code lab in addition the cloud security
scanner highly recommend that you guys
try it out its ability to find
vulnerabilities its ability to be very
very low noise and high signal so that
you can remediate directly and then on
the app side once it's on ji-ae there's
a couple different options so we talked
about going to App Engine directly or to
App Engine managed VMs where you can
bring your own programming system that
you're more comfortable and familiar
with moving the my sequel to cloud
sequel and that particularly for this
application which is image centric to
take advantage of the machine vision API
is that we have so with that again for
us the ability to go for a
third-generation cloud is really the
ability to combine security and
innovation and really build what's next
so thank you guys and both the meet
myself will be around to have any
questions
you
you